After an uneven final season comprised of
only six episodes, fans were excited, concerned,
and downright desperate to see how the Game
of Thrones saga would finally end.
From the Iron Throne to the fate of Westeros
and the final showdown between Daenerys and
Jon Snow, here's what the ending of Game of
Thrones means not just for the final season,
but for the entire series.
Beware: spoilers are coming!
After the burning of King's Landing in the
previous episode, several main characters
wander through the brutal aftermath, with
Tyrion Lannister, the Hand of the Queen, looking
stricken as he walks down ruined streets and
sees the bodies of those Daenerys burned without
mercy.
As he and Jon Snow survey the destruction,
Jon and Tyrion separately set off to meet
the queen.
Jon's journey finds him at odds with Grey
Worm over the execution of Lannister soldiers.
But soon after Tyrion sets off on his own,
he makes a horrifying discovery.
In a truly heartbreaking moment, Tyrion finds
the bodies of his brother and sister and breaks
down amid the rubble.
With the rest of his house literally entombed,
Tyrion finds himself suddenly alone, and in
that moment, his resolve to defy his queen
strengthens.
Later, as the Dothraki and Unsullied celebrate
their victory, Daenerys makes a grand entrance,
riding atop Drogon and landing in a perfect
shot with her silhouetted by his wings.
While she gives a full-throated victory speech
in which she praises her army for taking down
a tyrant and claiming the city as their own,
viewers know the truth: Dany is no better
than the tyrant she aims to replace.
In fact, she's probably a lot worse, as she
announces her plans to prolong the war and
conquer the rest of the world.
Daenerys has always bent towards justice,
but with this proclamation, it seems as if
she's finally gone too far, and even her most
trusted advisors seem frightened by her endless
hunger for power.
In the aftermath of the siege on King's Landing,
during which Tyrion begged his queen to show
mercy to those who couldn't defend themselves,
it seems as if the last remaining Lannister
can no longer bring himself to follow Daenerys,
and has seen her for what she really is - or
at least what she's ultimately become.
Daenerys is already furious with Tyrion after
finding out that he freed Jaime - which ultimately
doesn't even matter, considering that Jaime
and Cersei are both dead.
But Tyrion has his own grievances with the
Mother of Dragons.
As they confront each other atop a ruined
King's Landing, he admits that he freed his
brother, but reminds her that she decimated
an entire city.
Moments later, he tosses aside the badge that
identifies him as Hand of the Queen.
Daenerys immediately has him arrested, but
his point is made, marking yet another advisor
who leaves her side when she needs them the
most.
Her transformation into a new version of her
father, the Mad King, who killed anyone who
displeased him, is complete.
As Tyrion sits in captivity, awaiting his
certain execution, he's visited by a visibly
torn Jon Snow, who, despite his allegiance
to Daenerys, still obviously trusts Tyrion's
counsel.
Jon defends Daenerys at first, saying that
though he can't condone what happened, the
war is finally over.
But Tyrion persists, reminding Jon that Daenerys
isn't even close to finished, and the only
way she can achieve her ultimate goal is through
even more death and destruction on a global
scale.
Tyrion also reminds Jon that he once had the
power to do what Daenerys did - specifically,
to ride atop a dragon and destroy an entire
city - and he never would.
Before she sacked King's Landing, Daenerys'
destruction often seemed entirely righteous
- like when she freed slaves and killed their
masters - but as Tyrion points out, the murder
of countless innocent men, women, and children
can't possibly be defended, and at this point,
the Dragon Queen will stop at nothing to achieve
her goals.
Though Tyrion recognizes that "love is more
powerful than reason," he still does everything
in his power to convince Jon of the path ahead:
"You've tried to protect people.
Who is the greatest threat to the people now?"
Jon - the true heir to the throne, having
received wise counsel from the Hand - knows
that there's only one move left to finally
end the war once and for all.
Jon finds Daenerys in the Throne Room, admiring
the throne she's worked so hard to win.
As he asks her why she murdered children in
the streets of the capital, she tries to entice
him with her vision of the "new world" the
two of them can build together.
As they embrace, Jon proclaims that Daenerys
will always be his queen.
Just when it seems like all hope for peace
is lost, he stabs her, holding her and weeping.
This is the moment the series has been building
toward since the beginning.
Ned Stark lost his head for being too honorable.
In the end, Jon Snow betrayed his honor in
order to save it.
He made the impossible choice: killing his
lover and queen, to whom he'd pledged his
eternal loyalty, for the greater good of his
family and the world.
After Jon becomes the Queenslayer, all is
silent for a moment, until Drogon reappears,
coming face to face with Jon in a frightening
moment when it seems like the last remaining
Targaryen might immediately face justice for
killing the Mother of Dragons.
However, Drogon's anguish over the death of
his mother is directed not at Jon, but at
something entirely different - specifically,
the Iron Throne, which he torches into a melted
pile of slag in a stream of fire.
The ultimate symbol of power in Westeros is
completely destroyed.
Daenerys has always referred to her dragons
as her "children," and her final moments with
Drogon are heartfelt, as he tries to nudge
her awake and screams in pain for his lost
mother.
After demolishing the Throne once and for
all, Drogon gently lifts Daenerys off the
ground and flies away with her safely ensconced
in his claws, making for a fitting end to
Daenerys' arc.
She was reborn with all three of her dragons,
and even in death, she remains a part of her
only remaining child.
Moreover, Drogon identifies Dany's true killer
without uttering a word.
It wasn't Jon who is responsible for the end
of her life.
Instead, it was her unending quest to seek
the Iron Throne itself.
It's like Cersei said way back in season one:
"When you play the game of thrones you win,
or you die.
There is no middle ground.”
Since the beginning, the throne has represented
death.
It was composed of the weapons of the king's
enemies, and men and women fought and killed
for a chance to sit on it.
Daenerys always wanted to break the wheel.
Now that Drogon has destroyed the Iron Throne,
the wheel in Westeros has finally been broken.
Weeks after Daenerys' death, Tyrion is led
out of his cell to face a new council, made
up of familiar characters alongside a few
faces who have been absent from the show for
several seasons.
The Unsullied have taken King's Landing and
are holding Jon and Tyrion captive, and Tyrion
must not only argue his case against Grey
Worm, but for the entire council.
But before Tyrion's fate can be decided, the
lords and ladies of Westeros must choose a
new monarch.
As the group debates who should rule next,
Tyrion is asked whether or not he wants the
job.
He describes himself as the worst possible
choice, and no one really argues his points.
In order to explain who he does have in mind,
however, Tyrion begins by telling the assembled
that what unites everybody is the power of
a story, then identifying the person he says
has the "best story" - Bran Stark, who has
journeyed beyond the Wall and back to become
the all-seeing Three-Eyed Raven.
Everybody seems a bit stunned by this unexpected
nomination - except for Bran, but now that
he's the Three-Eyed Raven, looking surprised
isn't really his thing.
But once Tyrion points out that because Bran
can't have children, the leader of Westeros
will be chosen rather than receive it by birthright,
he receives a unanimous vote.
After everything the Starks have lived through,
the eldest surviving Stark son is named Bran
the Broken, First of His Name.
In exchange, Bran chooses Tyrion as his new
Hand, bringing his arc to a fitting conclusion.
As far as his own arc is concerned, Bran's
ascension to the throne may seem surprising
given the path his story has taken throughout
the series.
Moreover, in this final season, Bran doesn't
actually do much, aside from glower at other
characters from his chair and say weird things.
But if you remember the very first episode
of the series, Bran has a front-row seat to
an execution, carried out by his father.
The scene is meant as a lesson for Bran in
the rules of justice and leadership: namely
that duty and honor justifies violence and
death.
But now that Bran will take over as King of
Westeros in the wake of Daenerys's war crimes,
it seems like a sure bet that he'll have taken
his father's lesson and will apply the inverse.
Mercy, fairness, and justice trump duty and
honor, and are the only true path to peace
and life.
Since the beginning of the season, Sansa,
who has established herself as a fair leader
as well as a sharp and shrewd strategist,
has bristled at the thought of the North falling
under anyone's rule.
Throughout Daenerys' reign, she argued for
the North to maintain its status as an independent
territory with its own monarchs and wardens.
When Jon told her about his true parentage,
she immediately shared the information with
Tyrion, clearly hoping to keep control of
the North by not only keeping a tyrant from
taking the throne, but by putting a half-Stark
regent in power.
While that plan didn't pan out, Sansa ultimately
made sure the North was taken care of.
During the council meeting, Sansa is hesitant
to cast a vote in favor of Bran, and as she
turns to her brother and tells him that she
loves him and that she's sure he'll be a great
king, she insists that the North remain its
own territory, and Bran grants her request.
Thanks to Sansa, the North can keep its identity
and its independence, and since the North
always remembers, its citizens will certainly
remember what the Lady of Winterfell did to
protect them.
As for the rest of the characters, each of
them is seen off properly, with arcs completed,
stories told, and journeys finally finished.
Grey Worm sets off for Naath alone, still
smarting after losing both Missandei and his
queen.
Bronn returns to claim his lordship of Highgarden
and becomes Master of Coin in Bran's administration,
flanked by a small council that includes Brienne,
Davos, Sam, and Tyrion.
Podrick Payne, now Bran's attendant, has been
knighted and made a member of the Kingsguard
since viewers last saw him.
Not only are several stories completed, but
some characters write out stories of their
own, making sure the people they lost won't
be forgotten.
After finding Jaime's unfinished entry in
the book listing Westerosi knights, Brienne
completes it herself, capping it off by writing,
"Died protecting his queen."
Meanwhile, Sam presents the council with a
book written by one of the Maesters called
- what else?
- A Song of Ice and Fire, in an obvious and
rather heavy-handed reference to the book
series by George R.R. Martin on which the
series is based.
Unlike Martin's series, however, this book
appears to be finished.
Jon, for murdering the queen, is banished
back into the Night's Watch, a symbolic move,
and the only way the council can seem to broker
peace with the Unsullied and get them to relinquish
their hold on the city.
Upon returning to Castle Black, Jon reunites
with Tormund as well as a large group of wildlings
and his direwolf Ghost, who, despite missing
an ear, is thrilled to see his master once
again.
In the end, the series closes with shots of
the family with which it began - the Starks,
who have scattered to various corners of Westeros
and beyond.
Sansa is coronated at Winterfell, proudly
taking her seat as the citizens of the North
raise their swords and cheer for the new Queen
in the North.
Arya boards a ship headed for the unknown
lands west of Westeros, sailing under the
Stark banner on a quest to learn what lies
beyond the part of the world where their maps
end.
Meanwhile, Jon sets out from Castle Black
with Tormund, Ghost, and a group of wildlings
in tow.
As they begin their journey to the far North,
some green growth can be seen peeking out
from underneath the thick layers of snow.
Throughout Game of Thrones' run, audiences
have always been told that "winter is coming."
But now that the Night King is no more and
a new age has begun in Westeros, it seems
as if the show's long winter may finally be
coming to an end.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.